la rusia de vladimir putin ha sido
durante mucho tiempo admirada e incluso
cortejada por ma jin lepe en una
posición muy criticada desde la invasión
rusa de ucrania por lo que la cantidad
de agrupación nacional ha querido dejar
clara su visión se declara partidaria de
reforzar los vínculos entre la otan y
moscú que es tan pronto como la guerra
entre rusia y ucrania haya terminado y
tengamos un tratado de paz lo pondré un
acercamiento estratégico entre la otan y
rusia ratificó luto en el área si otra
medida defendida por marín depende la
retirada de francia del mando militar
integrado de la otan para recuperar más
soberanía asegura la candidata en
segundo lugar quiere poner fin a la
cooperación industrial con alemania una
posición justificada por los intereses
divergentes entre ambos países aunque la
candidata ya no defiende el éxito y el
abandono del euro sigue siendo crítica
con las limitaciones impuestas por la
legislación europea
una historia totalmente diferente es la
de su rival en el marco que es
abiertamente pro europeo
el presidente saliente aboga por una
unión europea fuerte y energéticamente
independiente
la lucha que estamos librando no es sólo
una lucha por francia es una lucha por
europa porque el proyecto de
ultraderecha que tenemos delante va en
contra del proyecto que yo defiendo en
nombre de muchos de los que están aquí
es un proyecto oculto ahora es más
ambiguo pero es un proyecto para salir
de europa
después de catalogar como muerte a la
otan en 2019 marco instó a la alianza a
unificarse justificando su decisión por
la guerra que está a las puertas de la
unión europea también pidió que se
aplicaran fuertes sanciones contra moscú
el actual presidente es partidario de la
estabilidad política en tiempos de
crisis una estabilidad que pretende
encarnar